yo what's up i'm hip dustin yeah yeah
yeah i'm dustin when he reaches the 90's
bright hip-hop and career eddie guys stranger
things episode two today get ready to enjoy
this reaction i'm assuming and hoping if uh you're
interested become a super sexy reject today where
you'll catch the full length watch alongs for
stranger things over there and we cover a whole
bunch of shows where some of them are reaction
highlights exclusives for patreon and if you can't
do that leave a like and it's not too hard to ask
is it also subscribe and click that notification
bell to notify when our next stranger things
reaction is up here on the channel and then boys
at prepper wouldn't be able to do the schedule we
got currently if it wasn't for each and every one
of you there hire them aft after after this minute
away from our work yeah yeah the love of god
oh
he simply ran away very plausible escape
i think all of us are predicting some crazy
explanation of like explosion sentiment to
something that transports maybe russia got
de-materialized turned into electrical current
and he was transported and spat back out he just
ran away he just jumped to the next level down
choice i'm in russia find
me in russia i'm a prisoner
looks like that munson boy's up to no good again
we heard there's a dutchess dragons game
going on over here put down the dice
holy mother of god no you guys
got to move out of hawkins
everybody needs to move out of hawkins i
can't be out here get back inside back inside
or are you a witness at all to my
videos suspicious yesterday perhaps
people returning to the trailer
we're out of hawkins it's a gift i uh i
hand picked those for you and hawkins i
know you like yellow but now i'm kind
of realizing that it's too much yellow
i know you also like purple so i got some
purple as well so i kind of did like a 70 30
split kind of thing perfect complementary
colors it's good all that writing she doesn't
just tell for me are your friends going
to meet us there friends what what friends
you know stacy and angela angela you'll meet
them i promise just not today i want today
to be about me and me and definitely not about
will at all i crime she crumpled this painting
the body of a hawkins high student was discovered
early this morning police have not yet released
the victim's name although we are told they're
currently in the process of notifying the family
the first season was like i'm kidnapping and this
one's a murderer yeah small town murder what's
this i thought we were watching thundercats
hugging student got murdered oh [__] oh
they say who it is no not yet hey maybe chrissy
didn't stand you up after all hey don't say that
this town's turned upside down yeah he's like
a super nice guy but then he's murdering women
on the weekends he's saying eddie is like
ted bundy it's more like richard ramirez
night stucco after i saw eddie and chrissy
go in the trailer something else happened
okay all right they really are
playing with time a lot yes i love it
maybe he was scared because you know he just
killed someone or amy but because something else
killed her but that's impossible not here i
don't know there's only one person who knows
what actually happened eddie oh [__] [__]
rusty where are you going to see your friend
you heard the news it's not safe good point
we'll be extra careful thanks mama love you bye
this looks and reads like a ransom note and a
bad one at that there's no proof of life here
yes there is it's signed enzo so so there's
only two people who knew about our date
at enzos and that's me and hop yes he's
sending me a message you saw him die joyce
i didn't see a body always room for a sequel he
evaporated or he survived okay okay what's he
doing in russia he was captured that's what ben
he probably met some new friends and by friends i
mean the kgb no matter how strong you think jim
is they will get his whole life story and yes
that might very well include a planned
date at enzo's with you his co-conspirator
you just made all that up
it's a theory this could be real hopper could be
alive i suppose there's only one way to find out
but go to russia we're gonna call that number
and we're going to find out who the hell sent you
that letter but we're doing it my way yeah buddy
who you work with no one oh this woman who is she
don't you tell me she's wearing a russian uniform
oh
some good noise dampening gloves
poor hopper man goes through all
that work to help save the day
she's capturing the torture gets tortured first
thanks i just i don't think mike's gonna like that
you're lying to him and he doesn't deserve
that when he finds out he's to be mad okay
god damn it l break my heart
come on will find love here at the roller
rink who's that twig with it i don't know
but it seems like the snitch has a boyfriend
i told you spring break is gonna be fun
chrissy doesn't mess with that crap
maybe someone talked her into it no
she she's straight as an arrow what about eddie
munson what does eddie have to do with all this
did he hurt chrissy
where are you going is everything good what
they say just gonna let him walk out there
man hey i hope he gets his revenge against
eddie that's right 100 on jason's side now
i need it i need it for what looking up eddie's
friend's phone numbers oh eddie your new best
friend eddie you think he's cooler than me because
he plays a nerdy game yes i never said that
work it out boys a student died and the game
plan is for you to let me do the talking for
you to take notes in that little pad there
and for you to follow my lead at all times
is that understood totally and completely
hi officer can't go through here we got a crump
c a friend she lives in there her mom is working
today and we would really like to check in on her
we're basically her nanny uh nannies actually i
do know you you're fred benson you killed that
kid last year what that ugly scar in your face
it was an accident an accident whoa that way
you ran all the way home instead of calling us
i said you're all right kid
you're looking a little peaked
huh fine i'm fine he's just
um on edge i mean we are
i'm loving the horror acceptance letter to lenora
community that's where i'm going but you're going
to emerson with nancy no she just doesn't
know it yet because if i told her the truth
then she just she'd just throw her dreams out
the window to come out here and be with me
no until eventually she hates me and then
and then before you know it we're just like
my mom and dad we're divorced my kids hate
me [__] yeah [__] i mean it's all good
palm tree the light that's what you
gotta do palm tree the light go go go go
got me stressed out's not even my girlfriend
where oh where have you been hiding
this handsome thing ugh angela
this is mike my boyfriend yo angela
come on friend let's skate shall we i i wanted
to finish the studio hold on to that come on
mike's like brother that was weird at
all go have fun lying to you mike [__]
no listen to me she's having problems
here problems okay what kind of problems
they're about to see that kind of problems
this is so upsetting they're
all going to laugh at you
beat those women mike beat it with your bare hands
oh my god this is such [__]
oh a crock of [__]
oh man she better go like full hog areas yeah
this is kgb they will still be
able to trace us eventually so
keep it brief how brief a minute max
and proof of life got it thank you
this is ansel hello enzo this is joyce i
received your message and i would like to make
a reservation yes good good but for reservation
you need to make deposit uh what what kind of
deposit forty thousand dollars hmm forty thousand
yuri's vision fly two days do not call again
well that wasn't the kgb but it wasn't a friend
either so we're both wrong he was strong american
make him a red guardian
yeah the place looks off
oh it's not come choco we're back with the
people who were listening on the phone calls
this transition so throwing me off yeah cops
they say chrissy went to him to buy drugs drugs
no that's what i said crazy
would never touch this [__]
it's like the ring probably sacrificed her
drain your blood for the devil i just said
you must do that why the cops go around
pursuing some some [__] leads spreading
rumors saying she's some some druggie no no she
wants to go out there she wants to do something
everything's always a basketball speech what did
i tell you when we went into semi-finals boys
nope does this reefer rick have a last name
right dr zhivago it's a double vhs it's long
hello so my boyfriend won't like totally puke when
i bring it home he's gonna he's gonna love it yeah
see ya yeah i'll see you later alligator light
is a dammit shot ah i beat you you think eddie's
guilty don't you whoa i believe in innocent until
proven guilty all that constitutional [__]
we've got a very big selection in here okay
it can be super overwhelming for these people
yeah it can be we'll lure them out
with vhs with free rentals with titles
no late fees let's narrow it down rick alderman's
latest rentals are annie and dumbo what are the
chances our drug dealers are family not likely
all right rick conroy 16 candles teen wolf and
romance english it's got to be all porn kimbrough
the blue lagoon and splash rick lipton fast times
at ridgemont yup yup yup yeah let's have it seven
times him it's probably the t 2121 holland road
that's out by lovers lake middle of nowhere it's a
perfect place to hide i wish they did all the rick
names and he was the last so we could just read
off titles well you want to tell us everything
nancy come on let's get out of here
but he's just the cutest little witness
stay here interrogate the dog yes
you're not gonna believe what this dogs
saw the whole thing it's all right here i'm just
looking for something about what happened last
night as far as i can tell you all have it
figured out already my nephew's a freak he
killed that girl i'm not about right let me guess
you've been speaking to the hawkins post oh my
god that guy's on agents of shield let's try to
figure it out let me tell your side of the story
do it enoch that poor girl i found this morning
same exact thing so i'm thinking maybe he broke
out like that what's his name white mask
kill the baby sitters ha yeah michael myers
he asked me victor's like that definitely
not like any other slasher character
victor creel gonna say this this season has like a
supernatural ghost slash
80s serial killer vibe yeah
fred don't kill fred i like fred fred's dead baby
oh my goodness all the mourners insidious
murderer murderer
this town's messed up crazy ass
bug-looking creatures now you got
ghosts and [__] the government should
just come aboard the whole place though
yeah the cinematography this
season is phenomenal it's
top-notch you translate that i
can't understand it it's too low
enhance what about all the speaker
systems you got from radio shack
she's mad at enzo calls him a moosa
moosa it's slain for what literally
translates to trash or garbage it's like
pig here often directed at cops cops
the restaurant you died at
joyce where you going the bank get enter is
damn money and we are getting popper back okay
well she was lying to you mike straight to
your face ever since you got here and and
i've been a total third wheel all day it's been
miserable so sorry if i wasn't i wasn't smiling
yeah whatever man he's your friend too come on
elle has like a book of letters from you that's
because she's my girlfriend will and us we're
friends well we used to be best friends oh then
maybe you should have reached out more i i don't
know why am i the bad guy let's just just find her
okay you guys are always having problems we fought
tooth and nail to rescue you she looks upset you
ruined my day i want you to say sorry to me and i
want you to tell my boyfriend that it was just a
joke we are really friends you'll just have to cry
to your daddy instead oh wait you can't do that
why a [__] [__]
take up kickboxing al oh
oh she's doing what she knows how to do
holy crap did she really do that yeah oh yeah
gear on the bottom of one
of those will jack you up ah
you [__] deserved it
yeah yeah but still it doesn't make
you feel better what did you do
that's what she knows angela coming fictional
character angela hadika i mean to be fair
i think a lot of people wanted to be in l's
shoes just then so her story is arthur fleck yes
eddie
i thought she was gonna smash the camera
like this each story is like
telling a different uh genre
some really great suspense building shots and
sequences too steve will get him with his orb i
know you think you're being funny henderson but
considering the fact that everyone in this room
has nearly died about a hundred times personally
i don't find it funny oh yeah we're on your side i
swear on my mother right guys yes yes from swear
on dustin's mother yeah dustin's dozen's mother
what if they just killed off steve
well that would he killed someone i want to know
what happened you won't believe me try me trust me
hi officer officer what are you still doing
here my friend from the car earlier i i can't
find him what do you mean you can't find
him he was there and then he was just gone
oh come on buddy
it's it in and she just like hung there
in the air her bones started to snap
we don't think you're crazy don't [__] me man
i know how this sounds we're not bullshitting you
we believe you recap all of seasons one through
three frames hidden beneath hawkins sometimes it
bleeds into ours there are some
things worse than ghosts who
oh
no there was nothing you could see or uh or touch
oh it's crazy what is he i want you to join me
oh or under a spell the curse effect this curse
why does he do it this way
oh
an undead creature of great power a dark wizard
yeah this is awesome
awesome awesome man attaching
yep more dread this season i like
it i like it a lot absolutely
i feel like this is definitely shaping up
to be better than last season but damn man
some dark ass [__] it's some darker [__] man
stop bad trip dewey cox hip-hop dustin's back
science raps as did all the things that we
were saying that would probably do you know
from after the first episode were like they really
focused a lot on the new characters i want them to
focus more on our returning characters and now
this was mainly about our returning characters
yeah we got us to learn that hopper was
still around and he just he just got taken
yeah he just lived and then got got
arrested blend his way out of there
and then he didn't break under interrogation
so they put him away to even crazier prisons
really thought there would just be some
kind of i don't know how i feel about that
yes i guess it's fine i don't know if it was just
some because i think a lot of us really thought it
was going to be some kind of crazy yeah particle
acceleration transporting thing and then things
were connected to russia the russians came over
here with their machinery yeah you know not just
i don't know we just said we just went away you
just you just jumped down and then we found him
right after that oh it's actually a lot simpler
in fact if joyce hadn't left like fourth with
she might have just found him too they had to
go man russians were coming that's true that's
true that's true it wasn't time yeah there wasn't
time so i'm still a little conflicted about that
it's funny it sets you up for some kind of big
explanation and then to have it be like oh no
no he just ran in the proper direction it doesn't
fully i guess circumvent the whole still how did
he survive that devastating explosion of this
theoretical machine uh but it's not something that
like while while yeah i'm sitting here thinking
about it uh it doesn't loom too heavily it's
not like it destroyed my enjoyment of everything
else they were doing you know well they said it
thoroughly explains how he uh why hasn't been back
yeah and i like to kind of gradually even still
like at the beginning of this episode i thought
they were going to rush him on and it's going
to be like all hopper all russia yeah but i like
that where yeah even you know we get hints at him
in the first episode now we get a couple glimpses
in this one well figuring out enzo and then having
the stories tied together yeah the way they deal
with time in this is really interesting the inner
cutting of all these different events i think the
cinematography is just [__] so beautiful it's
so beautiful wizard exquisite stuff and it does
feel different than the other seasons um like uh
not sure thematically what it is that is the
exact theme here of this one um because i think
the other three that are themes are really like
easier to identify whereas here we're dealing
with a lot of different things right now and
it's all really cool like i think everything is
really clicking there's not a single for longer
episodes there's not a single dull moment to me
and i like that it feels like a bunch of are parts
of it that you know like the it seems like with
with the dustin and you know robin and them they
they are still keeping that original flare of
the goonies vibe you know investigating
something horror um and and and then uh
i i think like there were like 80s there's
more 70s with like russian stuff yeah i mean it
still carries over but but yeah i feel like that
torture horror a psychological horror vibe yeah
and then this investigative mystery with nancy
and that genre kind of believes throughout of
this ghost story which i think is really cool
because they haven't done ghost story yet
at least like overtly no and it's a very i feel
like the upside down is a really interesting motif
to go into all these different iterations
of horror plus other genre and i feel like
ghost story is just as much at home in just
a different sense i wouldn't have necessarily
thought of it at first but i do think especially
the way they've done this whole possession and
praying on your guilt and your grief and and
using that as this this thing that you know has
a tangible counterpart but that only manifests
on our physical plane is gonna so go after max
yeah i know that's the thing is the second uh
the second chrissy got lifted off her feet in the
first episode i was like oh that trailer moment
where she's above the grave that's going to be
something to do with billy yeah yeah she probably
she's she's so he's so going after max and it's
already begun too with that little those little
flashes maybe if it's about overcoming your guilt
yeah yeah sure maybe that's what this season's
about and confronting it and not hiding
you know from it or not trying to soldier on like
it didn't actually happen yeah because the other
season last season was about moving forward um
second season was ptsd and this one is probably
a lot with everyone seems to be dealing with some
form of guilt guilt and especially survivor's
guilt i feel like yeah yeah yeah that's a
good way to put it man there's a lot that
happened these are these episodes they're great
though they're really good yeah i just want like
i know we got so many so much more hours
left to consume here um for this weekend but
i i think that what they're doing here is really
there's something kind of uh hypnotic about it
um it's really absorbing it's really really
absorbing you know transportive is the word like i
get so lost in it and a different flare you know
especially watching the other seasons and then
coming here this has more of a it's not slow but
it's more deliberate if that makes sense yeah it
feels like it's just allowed to take as much time
as it feels like it needs to with each thing not
too much not too little so yeah it's like every
emotional scene gets to be what it is but they
also have a really good sense of pacing for when
to either intercut with or introduce directly some
kind of eerie or ironic beat to keep the flavor
developing and unfolding you know there's more of
an ethereal unsettling quality to it yeah it's got
that foreboding where you just know like something
sinister is lurking and you just can't even
though we get glimpses in fekna and all that
stuff you still can't quite for a lot of the
regular scenes put your finger on it it's like
we know but i think they're good at also putting
you into that place of just something's off here
and it's hard to identify it's also a lot darker
more uncomfortable like those handheld shots that
they use just feel more more grounded in a reality
i got a really good contrast because there are so
many really beautifully executed and very fluid
transitions and things that you know require a
lot of planning and a lot of ingenuity uh but then
i think they they use those in juxtaposition so
that when they do deliberately switch to something
that's more handheld a little more voyeuristic it
really strikes you and i think they're also good
at choosing when to do that because i feel like
that's an easy thing to go for when you want
intensity but i feel like they've used it here
also not only for intensity's sake but like
they especially in the max scenes when she's
at home it's more just to kind of enhance
that realism yeah yeah you're really there
you know but but at the same time like it is it
feels like a choice and it feels striking but not
in a way where it's like super distracting it's
just like oh yeah it's another flavor they've
added to the repertoire because when i think of
the visual and the oral style of the show i think
of something symmetrical and steady you know i
guess the easiest way to narrow down what they're
doing here is the the other seasons rift on
sci-fi horror and this rips on supernatural horror
yeah yeah that's a good point yeah i like it
i'm really digging it a lot i think the the gore
gags are cool that whatever that method is that
maybe victor creel does of like snap their bones
pull back their eyes i'll be taking these yeah
one and two i'm like are those gonna come all
the eyes gonna come back or something like it
seems very deliberate and and he's out there
snapping people's limbs and taking their yeah i
was like jesus there's an mo for a killer this
is really you gotta have a lot of strength and a
lot of resolve because it's hard to do that i mean
with supernatural powers obviously much easier
with the real creole you know who i'm excited to
meet too like i like that uh i like it's funny
for as tension-filled and as horror-oriented as
these episodes have been i also too like that
you know vecna is still used sparingly and is
this very much sinister and looming presence and
we still haven't even gotten to robert england
well it's it's isn't robert e complaining guy
i think he's creel yeah yeah so like the guy
who eventually i assume soul rots and becomes
creole in the upside down yeah this creature
on the upside down yeah he's voicing him
yeah yeah because this vector character
is a combination of freddy krueger pennywise and
hellraiser and tyrant from resident evil yeah yeah
mainly the aesthetic yeah yeah yeah but the
qualities of 80s villain how are these 80s right
is 80s or 90s hellraisers 80s yeah yeah how really
hellraiser is the it was one when i revisited all
the 80s slasher franchises in a big way for the
first time hellraiser was the one that was just as
intense as i'd imagined from the outside yeah and
i remember being like damn for the 80s this one
did not hold back yeah this is this is a yeah and
also like how hell razor was a villain who could
because they used to have villains
before characters like hellraiser and
i guess the mini series for penny and freddy
krueger and stuff like like those kinds of
characters the villains usually were scary because
they didn't talk yes and then you had a dawn of
villains who could talk and they wouldn't
shut up who would have shut the [__] up
and this this is our first season that
and and like that's what i mean like after
there's a late 80s portion that is very specific
and it seems to really capture that and even does
capture some of those like 80s serial killer
vibes without going full tilt that direction
um without going full henry no yeah yeah might be
a 90s movie but just barely yeah yeah yeah just
just a bit but it's it's really fascinating what
they're doing and and like 11 story is one i'm
i wonder why she wants to put up the facade
though so much so for mike so much for mike
yeah like look how happy my life is and stuff
i wonder why she's so desperate to do that and
maybe it's just my whole thing with will last
season too of like you know you care about hanging
out with me mike and i'm like [__] mike man
cover passes yeah it has been a year why haven't
you tried and and why in this moment are you
like so quick i mean i guess you know teenagers
and romantic problems and blah blah blah but also
like i feel like you could act a little bit like
you guys are actually friends yeah because like
when will does confront him i'm like yeah i mean
it does seem like you've been third wheeling him
all day and you don't really seem to care about
being here with him he's just kind of there
and i mean unfortunately yeah and i mean i
i hope that the will story like i i i'm with
it right now and i appreciate it right now and
i hope that it grows into something where
that actor and that you know character can
shine well yeah it's a little repetitive for him
at this moment yes it's just deeper voiced older
yeah but it's at this point it's a little
repetitive so we'll see how the rest of it unfolds
like what specific path they put him on to because
it seems like they're building up something for
him they keep having these gazing slow shots on
him of just observing they keep faking me out too
because i always think that it's gonna zoom in
on whoever his potential love interest could be
but then no it's oh damn it's on the camcorder
guy who's gonna make this situation even worse
but uh yeah yeah hoping for hoping for will to to
be given something juicy here because i like what
they're doing in california in the sense that with
11 it's the most removed from any and everything
supernatural horror it's all grounded in reality
for 11 at this moment well they're doing carry
with her in a lot of ways yeah yeah yeah yeah but
even still like i'm not sitting here going get
back to the point where she has power like i i'm
actually i think they do a good job of putting all
that uh you know all that pulp and all those
exploitable elements and things into the rest
of what's going on so that you can have
what is right now at least just a very
personal human story happening around 11. well
it does they started off this season with showing
that i mean at least the way it's perceived that
she murdered everyone there at the rainbow room so
and then she gets she flashes back to that so
i mean so maybe that's like a big part of her
guilt too yeah maybe she has an overcome and you
re you still recreate you know if you haven't
overcome it yeah and um when she attacks
angela which by the way ball removed 100 for it
it's fictional all right because real life might
have a different saying still might be like okay
it's kind of deserving but yeah we all wanted
to but but you can't do it in terms of fiction
you know come on whatever screw it like they
oh well the true tradition of the 80s i mean
they they're not completely psychotic but
they are pretty extremely they're extreme
yeah yeah they're extremely bullied yeah they're
awful um and uh like what does angela expect
but i love how she always singles out angela
yeah i'm like they're all bad yeah but but take
cut off the head and the rest she's the queen
she's a queen bee yeah all these dudes ain't
[__] around her because she's the nucleus but i
wonder what their what portrait they're painting
or what path they're putting her on of you know
she's powerless right now and in all ways yeah
you know um friend wise social circumstance wise
she becomes desperate she just wants to be normal
and she doesn't have any physical powers and then
she strikes and she's looked upon as like this
like oh my god what did you just do this
violent threat she's haunted by her own
guilt from what she did in the past and you know
like what's it like is there an association that
having these power having the powers prior was
a bad thing you know i saw i'm curious to see
what path they put her on to what this all
ties to thematically and emotionally for her
of what her powers mean to her you know because
it's always seemed like a bit of a curse
so maybe gaining them back in terms
to fight the high school bullies you
they're going to be like we need you never going
to get back to indiana this whole season yeah it's
all going to be in l.a it's obviously california
trying to figure out social skills oh obviously
building to her getting her powers back and having
a fight like you're a race in the hole remember
yeah you're what we need on all the time we need
to do the thing i need you to do the thing yeah
and then go there and kill everyone at that high
school yeah lock them in the gym they're all awful
they are pretty much all awful that's that's
terrible yeah well no one's standing up for her
not not a single person not not anyone no one
is is decent to to jane oh god it really sucks
i i guess if you're we're alive for that period
of time in the 80s or or any time depicted in a
stephen king novel that features a bully let us
know is that anything approaching reality look
like if you were a freak with just everyone
the most terrible they could be at all times
it certainly seems that way from all 80s
movies from every 80s movie ever made yeah
it was shocking i didn't expect her to just i
really thought she was gonna break the camera
yeah i i thought she might actually hit her
i didn't expect them to to go full flex and
i think should have been practical effects yeah
fair yeah fair i mean i cuz two it's it might have
been hard i wonder i think that's an area where if
you are cut there like you do kind of bleed a lot
and so yeah i mean as much as i wish for a
practical effect it was still like oh that is
that is some nasty looking damage
and i'm sure for everyone around
that's not gonna help 11. i love how
everyone is just like why would she do that
that's the thing wasn't there like
a billion of you who just worked
not one of you could have made the connection
to oh yeah we were all unanimously ridiculing
this person on camera and we got the entire
establishment in on it maybe maybe she's mad they
and like you brought up before like generational
trauma i keep wondering if they're gonna go down
some type of cultist mentality in some areas
it could be they seem to explore that with
the bullying and then the basketball people being
like yeah they're all devil worshipers evil dies
tonight yeah which well yeah yeah i can definitely
see some uh i mean i like it through the scope of
the the basketball team that makes sense yeah
and then that guy like i that guy who was jason
or whatever his name is i i he's so someone's
gonna deep fake tom cruise's face onto his face so
tom cruise to me it's not even funny i do love
i do i do like that story i think it's this is
a really emotional and breathes really well and
uh i think it's really earning its run time yeah
that's really engrossing i'm like i mean you
know lucas doesn't want to stand up for anything
just gotta admit it's what we've played just
want to be popular just be like i played it once
yeah it's a fantasy game it's like it's it's
like a board game it's not actually satanism guys
i well let me show you yeah but you know i mean
his position then i i guess you know you don't
want it people really think about dungeons that's
i mean i'm sure i've never met those people but
yeah i mean satanic panic and yeah people singling
out heavy metal and dungeons and dragons yeah like
that's that's based on yeah hysteria yeah i
think that's where i was thinking about the
cultish fives with the satanic panic yeah well and
hey i mean maybe they'll do something to also nod
to that as either a misleader or maybe there is
some cult of vector out there or something but
uh it's fun wallpaper but i mean in fact there's
the dutches and dragons character but they're i
think they're calling the big bad vector tubes
yeah they nicknamed him because that's also the
motif is yeah every like monster out of the upside
down gets a name from demogorgon mind player yeah
so i'm just assuming there but yeah maybe
there is some kind of cult associated
i feel like everyone's so blind
with other things in hawkins
yeah there is this is a point where
it's like which feels very dary
yeah yeah yeah i mean dairy has that mumbo jumbo
like people seem to forget the weird [__] that
happens that's not built into here but yeah when
they were in that scene with eddie i was like
i guess maybe he wouldn't be aware of any of the
weird past several years of feeling like yeah
yeah it seems like he would have at least
some inkling or some rumblings about it yeah
yeah so that's a that's a piece of the continuity
i guess i'll have to check back on because i don't
know when things happen at the star court mog
gets pretty big in scope and scale but then
the biggest thing too yeah like that yeah like
nothing but to me i go back to season one where
will's body was found and then brought to a
morgue then they found out it wasn't really
will's body fake and then will came back from
the dead everyone's like oh well you're alive
you're trying to forget about that whole
body swapping weirdness thing yes yeah
what are what are the rest of the citizens of
hockey are they just uh are they just oblivious
it's like any and all of it yeah or do they just
i guess everybody must just sit around and go we
just live in a strange town accidents happen
every day i am not finding jonathan's story
that interesting so far it that's the only post
that's the only story that i'm like these jokes
are kind of flat and like this and it's it's
like a half-assed cheech and chong because they
don't want to go full tilt there but yeah it's
not that funny it feels really cliche of that
character i'm waiting for it to evolve and then
i don't know jonathan's story just seems so like
typical too so it seems yeah very kind of straight
and wrote and i can't foresee yet how it will grow
into anything that seems very significant his for
his story feels perfunctory because yeah we have
to include jonathan if it's here yeah it really
does because i was sitting there during the golf
scene where there were the two of them were you
know just chucking balls and and i was like going
back and forth thinking you know it's really cool
that they care about all their characters and they
found a way to give everybody something to do but
then by like the end of that sequence i was like
well what that scene ended and then later on
the episode i realized we're not cutting back
to him this episode yeah so yeah it's like it is
the least important seeming story and it trails
off the soonest and thus it does feel like yeah
we need to have him so we'll give him a scene
each episode yeah and that's about it
and maybe we'll use him for transpo
i can almost imagine argyle like eclipsing him
as a character because yeah cause like i like
that guy too and the interesting characters tend
to get something to do when they enter the plot
and become a part of the series regular cast or
whatever so yeah cause i'm not really torn between
her nancy and jonathan gonna break up i'm like
i don't i really love them a lot in season two
as like when they're getting together i really
rooted for them a lot the context really helps
their story and then here i'm like i just
really don't kind of kind of don't care
i don't see what's great enough beyond your you
know appearance and attitude that's like no no man
give them a chance i want them to work this out
yeah it's sort of like i half the time i was like
are nancy and fred going to get
together or something weird like that
when when they said goodbye to each other in
season three i found that really heartbreaking too
i found that genuinely heartbreaking um
when i rewatched it and it's weird to
it's only been a like a couple months since
i've seen that and then to come back here
and see what's going on with them i'm just
gone yeah they're probably gonna break them
yeah and i mean they have that one bit where
they're both talking about their relationship and
we get another beat in this episode where they're
both talking about the relationship and they feel
more i know they're disconnected by distance
but something feels disconnected about even they
don't even like call each other yeah like not even
like one phone call with each other yeah and again
like there's so many circumstances i get it but i
feel like at the same time i don't really buy the
struggle coming out of them like the dialogue
is there about how you know they're trying to
convince themselves about certain things and hey
maybe we need to break up or whatever but for
some reason it's the piece of drama that doesn't
actually ring very true or very true vital to me
it's uh yeah there's something about it it feels
like they're already broken up or like uh the plot
doesn't care that much it's hard to care about
them you don't see one interaction with them
yeah or give us a reason why beyond just what we
know from before as to why we'd want them to work
it out all right gang well here we are i've got
uh five more episodes ago so with this being this
change you think season four it's like 12 more
hours yeah yeah and then when part two comes out
we'll have 18 more hours beyond this i mean let's
look at it really quick oh let's look at the uh
uh let's do some quick math
oh next one's only an hour
okay so it's the last one that's forever yes
all right i'm looking forward to the number 45
they could have which i bet the series
finale they might do some kind of screening
oh it'd be great to be able to be
able to experience it that way nope
we have to be here we gotta be
here we gotta be here for you guys
and we want nothing else really don't yeah it's
the this is a fun show to share this is a fun
show to share yeah i love this show yeah i do
too all right guys see you for the next round
ricardo martinez you know why i wanted to shout
you out in stranger things episode dos because
there's a lack of hispanic representation in
stranger things that's exactly what i was gonna
say yeah yeah because as two non-hispanic people
we're gonna notice you're hispanic that's the
first thing we noticed we thought hey we could
work with it we could work with this one i mean
i got this like stoner a guy named argyle who
i think is hispanic he could be he's ethnically
ambiguous which means technically yes that is
a californian stoner from the 80s who's playing
on cheech and chung he's probably hispanic okay so
ricardo i think stranger things is due for someone
like you not some weird stoner cliche hispanic
dude from the 80s i'm talking a good housekeeper
or you know a good gardener yeah janitor at
hawkins high janitor hawkins hi a gangster yes
you know something that's not a cliche something
like that ricardo and i feel like you fit
any one of those identities a low rider guy those
are non-stereotypes imagine this ricardo martinez
stranger things season five pulls into hawkins
high low rider boom hydraulics going up and down
walks out and is like what's up
essay i want to be part of the group
ricardo you are not a cliche i mean i'm sure maybe
there's parts to you that have like some type of
uh yeah we all have our stuff everything ricardo
does is original original now one part honors
he rejects his best guy ever he goes i do or any
other heritage of any existing culture so unique
this went way off the rails look
thanks for being here recording
yeah trying to come up with something new
thank you for being here and uh you know
we're just messing around gracias gracias
amigo from us people all right god bless
you